[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Klaus Kleber guten Abend zehn
Jahre haben nicht gereicht so schnell
ist das Entsetzen von damals nicht zu
vergessen als nach und nach klar wurde
was hinter dem doppelten Selbstmord und
einem Wohnungsbrand in Zwickau steckte
eine beispiellose Mordserie aus
abgrundtiefen Hass gegenüber Menschen
aus anderen Ländern und Kulturen das
Land war herausgefordert
als Bundeskanzlerin der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland verspreche ich Ihnen wir tun
alles um die Morde aufzuklären und die
Helfershelfer und Hintermänner
aufzudecken und alle Täter ihrer
gerechten Strafe zuzuführen
daran arbeiten alle zuständigen Behörden
in Bund und Ländern mit Hochdruck
dieses Versprechen ist immer noch
unerfüllt in den Augen der Angehörigen
die erleben mussten wie sie zum Ziel der
Ermittlungen wurden weil nur das in die
Vorstellungswelt der Ermittler passte
diese Wunden sind nicht verschlossen
berichtet Franziska wunderlich
[Musik]
10 Kerzen für 10 Opfer im Zwickauer Dom
wurden sie entzündet um in jene zu
denken die ermordet wurden und um daran
zu erinnern dass sie starben weil ein
rechtes Terror-Netzwerk unentdeckt
agieren konnte
ich bin mir sicher dass Sie eins eint
der Opfer des NSU zu gedenken und für
Toleranz für Menschlichkeit und für
Demokratie einzustehen denn bei allem
staatlichen und behördlichen Bemühungen
das zu Recht gefordert wird gilt es
kommt auf jeder und jeden von uns an
dass der Tag heute in Zwickau ganz im
Zeichen des Gedenkens und der
Aufarbeitung Stand ist vor allem einem
zivilgesellschaftlichen Engagement zu
verdanken seit Jahren organisieren
Matthias Blei und seine Mitstreiter
entsprechende Projekte und Aktionen sie
gaben auch den Opfern des NSU ein
Gesicht das ist und wie man sieht sehr
wichtig und ja es war auch gerade mal
sehr ergreifend jetzt bei der
Gedenkveranstaltung im Dom klar vergisst
man immer mal wieder im Alltag und und
man braucht solche Tage und man fragt
sich auch manchmal ob man wirklich ein
Gedenktag in festen braucht um daran zu
erinnern sich mit dem Thema zu befassen
und unsere Aufgabe ist es halt genau das
zu verhindern dass man so an dem
Gedenktag macht
und deshalb sorgten sie für einen Ort
des Gedenkens vor zwei Jahren pflanzten
viele Unterstützer der Idee zehn Bäume
am Schwanenteich am Fuße geht es
einzelnen erinnert eine Gedenktafel
wollen wir wachsen wie das wie das Leben
wächst wie ein Charakter wächst und
weil Bäume hoffentlich auch noch länger
leben als Menschen und uns vielleicht
noch überleben und auch für die
nachfolgenden Generationen
noch ein waren mal sind von diesem Ort
aus soll das Gedenken weiter wachsen in
Absprache mit den Angehörigen und
Städten sollen Bäume versendet werden
das sind das bei symbolische Bäume die
Familien haben natürlich die Möglichkeit
sich ihren eigenen Baum auszusuchen und
das sind wir gerade in der Absprache das
wird dann nächstes Jahr passieren
Hamburg hat schon Wünsche geäußert
Nürnberg ist es gerade ein Absprache und
ja Heilbronn ebenso statt Bäume zu
pflanzen hätte manch einer in Zwickau
lieber Gras über das Thema NSU wachsen
lassen damit aber genau das nicht
passiert dazu hat auch der heutige Tag
beigetragen
und das war eben leider nicht
konsequente Ermittlungsarbeit die den
sogenannten
nationalsozialistischen Untergrund am
Ende zerstörten es waren die Täter
selbst in einer Szene die einem die
Banalität des Bösen vor Augen führte in
einem biederen Wohnwagen den zwei der
Mörder zu ihrem letzten Tatort machten
als sie die Waffen gegen sich selbst
richteten Christian deker über Lehren
die gezogen wurden und die Frage ob es
genug sind
als dieses Wohnmobil in Eisenach heute
vor zehn Jahren in Flammen aufgeht Arndt
Gamze Kubasik noch nicht dass darin die
Mörder ihres Vaters liegen überhaupt ist
für sie bis heute noch vieles ungeklärt
es ist halt für mich immer noch sehr
traurig also es nimmt mich
sehr mit dass ich heute noch hier sitze
und so viele Fragen noch habe die ich
noch nicht beantwortet bekomme trotz
zahlreicher Ermittlungsverfahren und
Untersuchungsausschüsse sind bis heute
wichtige Fragen nicht geklärt wie kam
das Trio an die vielen Waffen wie wurden
die Opfer ausgewählt und vor allem
existierte rund um die drei ein größeres
Netzwerk
Selbstkritik heute beim
Verfassungsschutz die
Sicherheitsbehörden haben seinerzeit
eklatante Fehler begangen und heute
müssen wir diese Fehler aufarbeiten die
Sicherheitsbehörden Polizei
Verfassungsschutzbehörden von Bund und
Länder haben seinerzeit nicht gut
zusammengearbeitet die einzelnen Fälle
wurden isoliert voneinander bearbeitet
und wegen dieser isolierten Bearbeitung
fehlte der Gesamtüberblick die
Terrorgruppe wurde so viel zu spät
entdeckt um das in Zukunft zu verhindern
wurde das gemeinsame Extremismus und
terrorismusabwehrzentrum gegründet die
Sicherheitsbehörden von Bund und Ländern
sollen hier effizienter Informationen
austauschen
in den Parlamenten untersuchten bislang
insgesamt 13 Untersuchungsausschüsse die
Fehler
wir haben als Folge unserer Arbeit 47
Empfehlungen ausgesprochen und es wurde
viel bei den Sicherheitsbehörden
verändert bei der Polizei den
Nachrichtendiensten der Justiz aber auch
in der Politik und all das was wir getan
haben also neue Strukturen bessere
Informationsaustausch ist sicher sehr
hilfreich er muss aber auch gelebt
werden es muss verinnerlicht werden
damit sich solche Dinge eben nicht
wiederholen Irene mihalic damals
ebenfalls Ausschussmitglied sieht
dagegen wesentliche Punkte nicht
umgesetzt zum Beispiel wissen wir immer
noch viel zu wenig über das Phänomen
rechtsterror wir wissen immer noch zu
wenig über radikalisierungsprozesse auch
in den Sicherheitsbehörden ist auch
strukturell insgesamt noch zu wenig
passiert um solche Phänomene besser und
frühzeitiger zu erkennen sebastian
schamer ist Anwalt und vertrat gamsik
Kubasik im Münchner nsu-prozess er
kritisiert vor allem den Umgang mit
v-personen also Informanten aus der
rechten Szene erhält die Empfehlungen
der Untersuchungsausschüsse für
unzureichend umgesetzt
und das im Grunde genommen die Fehler
die damals passiert sind heute anders
fortgesetzt werden ein Beispiel
ein großer Kritikpunkt war das Führen
von vorpersonen in der rechten Szene
durch die Verfassungsschutzämter
insbesondere auch vorbestraften vor
Personen das ist danach quasi
legalisiert worden
Hinterbliebene wie gamsik kubasic
fordern dass die Ermittlungsbehörden die
offenen Fragen endlich klären einen
Schlussstrich hat die Bundesanwaltschaft
jedenfalls noch nicht gezogen in
Karlsruhe laufen noch mehrere
Ermittlungsverfahren
die mittlerweile
Bundestagsabgeordnete Janine Wissler
Ko-Vorsitzende der Linkspartei hat
seinerzeit im Untersuchungsausschuss des
hessischen Landtages mitgearbeitet und
ist bis heute überzeugt dass die
Ermittlungen nicht abgeschlossen sein
dürfen nah sein gökte mir fragt sie nach
dem Warum im Journal Update um 0.30
die corona-pandemie hat heute
rekordinfektionszahlen geliefert passend
zum Auftakt einer weiteren Konferenz der
17 Gesundheitsminister und Ministerin
die sich die Bundesrepublik leistet 16
jeweils für ein Land eine im Bund
derzeit sind sie nicht durch eine
gemeinsame Grundhaltung verbunden
niemand kann zuverlässig sagen wie viel
Anteil von verwirrenden
Datenübertragungen am
Feiertagswochenende in der Gesamtzahl
der heute gemeldeten Infektionen steckte
die auf der Basis von sieben Tagen
ermittelte Inzidenz lässt sich von
Ausreißern weniger beeinflussen und sie
tendiert deutlich nach oben
Entscheidungen sind gefragt und sie sind
umstritten Alexander Pool berichtet aus
Lindau bevor er seine Ministerkollegen
aus den Ländern empfängt besucht Klaus
holitschek noch einen impfbus der vor
dem Tagungshotel in Lindau seine Türen
öffnet eine der ersten impfkandidatinnen
Christel Schuh aus Freiburg die hier
ihre dritte corona-impfung erhält in
Freiburg ist sehr schwierig ein Termin
zu prägen für eine boosterimpfung
bedauer des wochenlang das frage ich
hier einfach mal bin hell begeistert
dass es so unkompliziert geht die 16
ländergesundheitsminister die hier in
Lindau Tagen sind sich einig die
booster-impfung ist ein entscheidender
Weg aus der Pandemie und ich glaube man
hat sich schon verständigen können dass
es wichtig ist diese
Auffrischungsimpfungen schon in einer
größeren Art und Weise durchzuführen wir
wissen aus den Daten von Israel dass wir
mit diesen booster-impfungen
möglicherweise auch die Chance haben
diese Welle noch mal deutlich
zurückzudrängen
zur Eindämmung der corona-pandemie ist
aus Sicht der Gesundheitsminister
außerdem ein verbindlicher Rechtsrahmen
notwendig ein Rechtsrahmen wie in die
Feststellung der epidemischen Lage
geschaffen hat diese Notlage nicht zu
verlängern aus Sicht der Bundesländer
ein Fehler wir sind mitten in einer
epidemischen Notlage noch drin das will
ich an dieser Stelle auch noch mal
erklären wir brauchen als Länder ganz
klar eine bundeseinheitliche gesetzliche
Grundlage dass wir bestimmte
Schutzmaßnahmen auch durchsetzen können
Bundesgesundheitsminister Jens Spahn
hatte sich noch Ende Oktober für die
Beendigung der epidemischen Notlage
ausgesprochen er zeigt sich
gesprächsbereit muss der deutsche
Bundestag entscheiden die rechtliche
Grundlage ist entscheidend das habe ich
immer gesagt Einigkeit unter den
Gesundheitsministern herrscht weiterhin
zum Thema Impfpflicht die soll es etwa
in Pflegeheimen nicht geben
als diese Konferenz vor vielen Monaten
geplant wurde da gab es schon eine
Tagesordnung dafür Punkt eins sollte
sein Lehren aus der corona-krise man war
sich damals sicher dass das der richtige
Zeitpunkt Zeit würde jetzt weil die
Sache doch bis dahin bestimmt vorbei
sein Stefan das ist sie nicht die
Pandemie ist noch da und die Linie der
Politiken im Bund und Länder uneinig wie
eh und je kann da was rauskommen in
Lindau
da kann was rauskommen allerdings werden
das nicht harte Beschlüsse sein sondern
konkrete und sehr aufschlussreiche
Trends nehmen wir mal zwei raus das
erste sind die booster-impfung es
zeichnet sich hier bei den
Gesundheitsministern ein Konsens darüber
ab dass man diese booster-impfung also
die Auffrischungsimpfungen möglichst
schnell möglichst allen anbieten will
die ihre Zweitimpfung schon sechs Monate
hinter sich haben also das wäre dann die
Abkehr dieser Altersstaffelung die wir
bisher erlebt haben und dann würde es
heißen dass 10 Millionen oder über 10
Millionen Menschen ab sofort ihre
Auffrischungsimpfung bekommen könnten
der zweite Trend den man hier ableiten
kann in Lindau das ist ein etwas
heiklerer und der betrifft die
Einschränkung die wir den Winter über
wahrscheinlich wieder in größere Maße
als bisher erleben werden darauf
schwören die Gesundheitsminister hier
ein also Zugangsbeschränkungen für die
Gastronomie für Großveranstaltungen aber
eben nicht flächendeckend für alle
sondern für den ungeimpften Teil der
Bevölkerung und damit sind wir jetzt
beim Hauptunterschied der heutigen
Situation zu der vor einem Jahr an die
sich viele erinnert fühlen aber den
heutigen Zustand definiert die Politik
hier in Lindau ist das oft zu hören
gewesen als eine Pandemie der
ungeimpften und leitet daraus eben auch
den Anspruch ab
sozusagen lockdowns für ungeimpfte
machen zu können für den ungeimpften
Teil der Bevölkerung das wird sicher
eine heftige Debatte auslösen können
dass die Minister da einfach so
beschließen
einfach beschließen können Sie das nicht
denn ein dritter Streit der dreht sich
noch um die Frage der Rechtsgrundlage
wir haben es den Beitrag gehört die
epidemische Lage läuft Ende November
eigentlich aus es gibt aber großen Unmut
darüber hier bei den Länderministern und
deswegen wird morgen wahrscheinlich hier
der Appell nach Berlin ausgesprochen
doch noch mal über die Verlängerung
dieser epidemischen Lage nachzudenken
denn die würde es den Ländern einfacher
machen auch einheitliche
corona-maßnahmen zu ergreifen und dieser
Appell richtet sich nach Berlin und dann
ist zweierlei gemeint zum einen die
jetzt noch amtierende Koalition aber
dann eben auch die sich jetzt
abzeichnete Ampelkoalition Unterführung
von Olaf Scholz und dieselbe Pandemie
Dankeschön Stefan und hier geht es
weiter mit Nachrichten von Gundula Gaus
auf dem weltklima-gipfel in Glasgow
haben Dutzende Länder einen
Kohleausstieg in den 2030er Jahren ins
Auge gefasst in einem weiteren Beschluss
erklären über 20 Länder die Finanzierung
fossiler Brennstoffe zu beenden
Umweltschützern gehen die Pläne nicht
weit genug auch weil etwa China die
Unterstützung verweigert zugleich zeigt
ein in Glasgow veröffentlichter Bericht
dass der Ausstoß an CO2-Emissionen in
diesem Jahr fast wieder auf dem Niveau
von vor der Pandemie liegen wird im
kommenden Jahr sei gar ein neuer
Höchstwert zu erwarten China verursachte
2020 demnach knapp ein Drittel der
weltweiten CO2-Emissionen
die SPD-Vorsitzende Saskia esken will
erneut für die Parteispitze antreten sie
wolle den mit dem scheidenden Co-Chef
Walter borjans eingeschlagenen Weg
fortsetzen erklärte sie und wünsche sich
eine Kandidatur von
Generalsekretär Lars Klingbeil für die
Doppelspitze geplant ist die Wahl auf
einem Parteitag vom 10 dezember an da
die SPD bei der Trennung von
Regierungsposten und Parteispitze
bleiben möchte zeichnet sich ab das
äskin kein Ministerium übernimmt
in Äthiopien hat das Parlament den
landesweiten Notstand bestätigt somit
kann die Regierung von Ministerpräsident
Ahmed weiter das Militär gegen die
volksbefreiungs von T3 einsetzen und
Bürger zu Militärdienst einberufen die
internationale Gemeinschaft fordert
zugleich eine sofortige Waffenruhe ein
us-sondergesandter bemüht sich in Addis
Abeba um Vermittlung
unterdessen marschierenkämpfer aus T3
weiter Richtung Hauptstadt seit einem
Jahr kämpfen nun Rebellen Anhänger der
einstigen eliteintegrai und
Zentralregierung um die Macht
bei mehreren Einsätzen im Mittelmeer hat
das private Rettungsschiff Ci4 mehr als
800 Menschen an Bord genommen ein
Viertel davon Kinder die zum Teil direkt
aus dem Meer gerettet wurden die
Hilfsorganisation sucht nun nach einem
sicheren Hafen für die CI an deren Bord
die Situation eng und belastet ist die
italienischen Behörden haben noch keine
Genehmigung erteilt bislang kamen allein
in Italien in diesem Jahr fast 54.000
Flüchtlinge und Migranten an
Europa hat zunächst ein Riesenglück
gehabt vor 30 Jahren im Kalten Krieg
hatten viele Szenarien der Militärs für
den Ausbruch eines neuen Weltkriegs
begonnen mit einem Zerfall Jugoslawiens
in seine ethnischen und religiösen
Bestandteile so kam es nicht der viel
völkerstaat hat den Fall des Eisernen
Vorhangs tatsächlich ein paar Jahre
ausgehalten und es gab dann schon so
etwas wie eine neue europäische
Friedensordnung als das Land dann doch
in blutigen Bürgerkriegen zerfiel
zunächst verfiel Jugoslawien insgesamt
und dann nochmals die Teilrepublik
Bosnien-Herzegowina bis heute wird sie
mühsam zusammengehalten vom fragilen
Friedensabkommen von Dayton und jetzt
Flammen die alten Konflikte wieder auf
vor allem bosnische Serben wollen ihre
Ecke des kleinen Landes abtrennen und
mancher träumt vom Anschluss an das alte
große Serbien eine Art
überregierungschef der hohe Gesandte der
Vereinten Nationen soll das verhindern
zur Zeit ist erst ein deutscher und ein
machtloser Mann Wolf Christian Ulrich
berichtet
auf dieser Brücke wurden 1992 zwei junge
Frauen von serbischen Scharfschützen
erschossen die ersten Opfer des
Bosnienkrieges der deutsche Christian
Schmidt soll neuen Krieg verhindern als
Hoher Repräsentant der internationalen
Gemeinschaft wacht er darüber dass
Bosnien und Herzegowina friedlich bleibt
glaube auch dass die Menschen das nicht
wollen die wollen nicht dass hier wieder
geschossen wird doch aktuell erlebe
Bosnien und Herzegowina die größte
existenzielle Gefahr seit dem Krieg so
Schmidt in einem Bericht an den
UN-Sicherheitsrat diese Woche ich habe
wirklich ernsthafte Sorgen über die den
Erhalt einer guten und auch eine
friedlichen Entwicklung in diesem Land
Schuld daran so heißt es im Bericht sei
dieser Mann Milorad dodek Anführer der
bosnischen Serben er versuche den
serbischen Teil von Bosnien und
Herzegowina abzuspalten
wir wollen uns aus drei Feldern
zurückziehen sagt er und fordert eine
eigene Armee für den serbischen Teil des
Landes ein eigenes Steuersystem und
eigene Sicherheitsbehörden
Folklore in Präsidialamt Dodik
boykottiert und blockiert staatliche
Institutionen wo er kann vor allem aber
will er Christian Schmidt loswerden der
auf die Einheit von Bosnien und
Herzegowina achtet
dafür hat Dodik mächtige Paten gefunden
die russische Regierung hat gestern im
UN-Sicherheitsrat wiederholt klargemacht
dass sie keinen Hohen Repräsentanten
mehr will das würde Dodik freie Hand
geben
von den Serben im Land bekommt er jedoch
nicht nur Beifall dragojup derikonja hat
im Krieg auf serbischer Seite gekämpft
heute kümmert er sich um die Belange von
anderen Veteranen und Hinterbliebenen
was hält er von dodex verbalem zündeln
es wird keine Abspaltung geben es wird
keinen Krieg mehr geben und es sollte
auch keinen Krieg mehr geben vor allem
die jungen Leute sind gegen den Krieg
sie wollen Arbeit und Wohlstand darum
sollten sich die Politiker lieber
kümmern
die Narben des Krieges sind in Bosnien
und Herzegowina noch immer an vielen
Stellen sichtbar die PR-Agentur von
Vesna Beganovic in Sarajevo gibt es seit
es den Frieden gibt im Land das dodic
dauernd die Einheit und damit den
Frieden in Bosnien und Herzegowina in
Frage stellt findet sie einen Skandal
solche Rhetorik schadet der Wirtschaft
es will doch niemand in politisch
instabilen Ländern investieren das alles
sorgt nur dafür dass noch mehr gut
ausgebildete junge Leute unser Land
verlassen
Rhetorik löst zwar kein Problem im Land
vor allem nicht die Armut doch es nutzt
ihm und seiner Clique 26 Jahre nach dem
Krieg wird dadurch viel
Versöhnungsarbeit in Bosnien und
Herzegowina zerstört
Fähre Berichterstattung über die Welt
Klimakonferenz in Glasgow verlangt die
Leistungen der Briten bei der
CO2-Reduktion zu würdigen die Leistung
eines Landes das mit Öl und Gas der
Nordsee fette Jahrzehnte erlebt hat und
sich davon mehr und mehr trennen musste
auch weil die Vorräte zur Neige geben
die Briten haben sich in ihrem
Energiemix außerdem stark auf ihre
Kernkraftwerke verlassen von denen viele
bald altersschwach aus dem Dienst gehen
werden und jetzt setzt die Regierung
Johnson offensiv auf eine Renaissance
der Kernkraft Andreas Stamm berichtet
ein Anblick der bei arune und Miguel ein
Hochgefühl auslöst fast kindische Freude
jedes Mal hinklipoint C der seit zwei
Jahrzehnten erste neue Atomreaktor
Britanniens die beiden sind Mitglieder
des Jugend nuklearnetzwerks mehr als
1200 Ingenieure Wissenschaftler Technik
begeisterte unter 37 die für eine
strahlende Zukunft des Atomstroms
kämpfen
nichts wird verbrannt eine vollkommen
saubere Energie verlässlich immer
verfügbar ich widme dieser Technologie
mein Leben es ist ein so großer Baustein
bei der Lösung des Klimaproblems
zusammen mit den Erneuerbaren
zu diesem Schluss kommt auch die
britische Regierung setzt auf seine
natürlichste Ressource mit riesigen
Windparks zusätzlich braucht man für
klimaneutrale Stromerzeugung bis 2035
Atomkraft und neue Reaktoren denn alt
Mailand 8 Standorten die 20% des
britischen Stroms produzieren müssen bis
dahin vom Netz dafür soll hinklipoint 10
5 energieliefern und ein zusätzlicher
Reaktor gebaut werden
seit 20 Jahren ist der Verbrauch an
fossilen Energieträgern konstant
geblieben obwohl so viel mehr grüner
Strom produziert wurde um klimaneutral
zu werden brauchen wir noch mehr
Atomenergie
Luftverschmutzung töte mehr Menschen als
Radioaktivität ergänzt Miguel die
Technologie sei immer sicherer das
Endlagerproblem lösbar umstrittene
Thesen dass die Baukosten für
hinklipoint C sich auf rund 27
Milliarden Euro versiebenfacht haben der
Atomstrom nur fließen kann durch
Milliardensubventionen das stimme so
Aron und Miguel aber niemand sage dass
Klimaschutz nichts kosten würde die
Versprechungen der atomaktivisten
verfangen in Großbritannien bis zu 80%
sprechen sich in Umfragen für die
Kernenergie aus den Verlockungen des
Atoms könne man leichter liegen erklärt
Brian smettley seit 30 Jahren Stadtrat
in Bridgewater unweit von henkley Point
doch statt wie versprochen blühende
Landschaften mache der Neubau
hauptsächlich Probleme
Befürworter dachten es würde viele Jobs
für Einheimische bringen viele Jobs ja
aber für Ortsfremde die hier auftauchten
was unsere miet und Immobilienpreis
Krise verschärft hat
viele junge Leute sind gekommen junge
Männer was zu Problemen bei der
Sicherheit mit Ruhe und Ordnung geführt
hat
Problems Hinkley Point glaubt der
Stadtrat sei ein notwendiges Übel damit
Britannien seinen Klimaschutzbeitrag
leisten kann wie Deutschland das
schaffen will für die atomaktivisten ein
Rätsel
bei uns herrscht ein besseres
Verständnis dafür dass kernenergieteil
der Lösung ist an Deutschland gerichtet
sage ich
in der Klimakrise müsse die Welt mit
einer Stimme sprechen heißt es gerade
oft beim weltklima-gipfel in Sachen
Atomenergie zeigt sich wie schwer das
ist
der 2011 beschlossene Atomausstieg
Deutschlands wird seit Jahren diskutiert
und in diesen Wochen werden die Fragen
lauter ob Deutschland nicht zurück zur
Kernkraft sollte um die Klimaschutzziele
einzuhalten weil rehhalla wie
realistisch wäre denn überhaupt eine
Rückkehr zur Kernkraft in Deutschland
ziemlich unrealistisch wir haben mit
Betreibern hier in Deutschland
gesprochen und da heißt das eindeutig
daran rütteln wir nicht der Ausstieg aus
der Kernenergie sei gesellschaftlicher
Konsens und unternehmerische Planung die
Betreiber selbst scheinen keinen
besonders großes Interesse daran zu
haben das Rat der Zeit zurückzudrehen
der Ausstieg aus der Atomkraft trägt
dein Datum Ende kommenden Jahres soll in
Deutschland das letzte Kernkraftwerk vom
Netz gehen der GAU in Fukushima und die
noch ungeklärte Endlagerung hat die
Kernenergie in weiten Teilen der
Bevölkerung untragbar gemacht außerdem
zahlen sich Wind und Sonnenenergie aus
nach jahrelangen milliardenschweren
Förderungen off den Wind sagt uns ein
Betreiber sei inzwischen deutlich
wirtschaftlicher als Kernenergie die
Konzerne in Deutschland haben sich so
scheint es der Energiewende längst
verschrieben und ihr Geschäftsmodell
darauf ausgerichtet ein Blick auf den
DAX der heute rekordverdächtig unterwegs
war rauf zum Allzeithoch dass er am Ende
aber nicht ganz halten konnte heißt
diskutiertes Thema in Brüssel ist auch
ob die EU die Atomkraft als nachhaltig
einstuft bekommt die Kernenergie diesen
grünen Stempel käme das einer Empfehlung
gleich in Atomanlagen zu investieren die
Liste was nachhaltig ist und was nicht
in den Augen der EU soll noch dieses
Jahr veröffentlicht werden und die
Diskussion werden weitergehen vielen
Dank Valerie nach Frankfurt
eine 28 Jahre alte Frau aus Solingen ist
wegen Mordes aus Heimtücke an fünf ihrer
sechs Kinder zu einer lebenslangenhaft
Strafe verurteilt worden das Landgericht
Wuppertal stellte zudem die besondere
Schwere der Schuld fest was eine
Haftentlassung nach 15 Jahren
ausschließt im September 2020 hatte die
Frau wahrscheinlich selbst
Missbrauchsopfer ihre ein bis acht Jahre
alten Kinder getötet nachdem sich ihr
Mann von ihr getrennt hatte ein Sohn
überlebte da er nicht zu Hause war
der Moderne Fünfkampf wird nach Olympia
2024 ohne die Teildisziplin reiten
stattfinden hintergrund ist der Vorfall
um die deutsche Annika schleu bei den
Spielen zuletzt in Tokyo ihr wird
Tierquälerei vorgeworfen weil sie gegen
das ihr zugeloste und völlig
verunsicherte Pferd Gerte und Sporen
einsetzte
schwimm Olympiasieger Florian Wellbrock
hat bei der Kurzbahn EM im russischen
Kasan Gold gewonnen mit deutscher
Rekordzeit über 1500 Meter Freistil
setzte sich der 24-Jährige in 14 Minuten
9 Sekunden und 88 Hundertstel gegen
dauerkonkurrent Gregorio paltrinieri aus
Italien und seinem Teamkollegen Sven
schwarz durch für Wellbrock ist es die
erste internationale Medaille im 25
Meter Becken
in der Fußball Europa League hat
Eintracht Frankfurt am Abend sein
Gruppenspiel bei Olympiakos Piräus 2:1
gewonnen Frankfurt ist damit bereits
vorzeitig für die Ko-Runde qualifiziert
das Verhalten von Fußballfans war heute
Thema am Bundesgerichtshof höchst
richterlich wurde bestätigt dass der DFB
weiterhin die Fußballclubs wegen
Fehlverhaltens von Zuschauern mit
Geldbußen belegen darf und nicht die
Krawallmacher selbst die zum Beispiel
verbotene Bengalos zünden die
Vereinsstrafen seien eine
Präventionsmaßnahme so der BGH das
funktioniere in der Praxis nicht behaart
Regionalligist FCK Zeiss Jena der
geklagt hatte und jetzt über eine
Verfassungsbeschwerde nachdenkt
mit dem renommierten Hans-joachim
friedrichspreis werden jährlich
Fernsehjournalisten ausgezeichnet die
Herausragendes leisten diesmal erhalten
ihn der Dokumentarfilme Karl giersdorfer
für seine Langzeitbeobachtung Charité
Intensiv Station 43 in der ARD so wie
unsere Kollegin Katrin Eigendorf die
zdf-reporterin habe mit der Reportage
Rückkehr der Taliban Mut können und
authentische Empathie für die Opfer
eines historischen Versagens bewiesen
hieß es am Abend bei der Preisverleihung
in Köln
Abend war es wir gratulieren Kathrin
sehr herzlich und weißen auf Maybrit
Illner hin Inzidenz steigt Immunität
sinkt wieder ein Winter und wieder kein
Plan ist die entscheidende Frage bleiben
Sie bei uns bis morgen tschüss guten
Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend dass die Väter das
inzwischen bereits die Ostseeküste
erreicht hat zieht morgen weiter über
das Baltikum in Richtung Nordosten es
wach damit den Weg frei für ein neues
Hoch das ist das Hoch Sylvie und
zusammenbringen die recht kühle Luft zu
uns nach Mitteleuropa aber es ist ja
auch November da erwarten wir ja nicht
mehr hohe Temperaturen jetzt in der
Nacht regnet es noch kräftig weiter hier
zwischen Mecklenburg-Vorpommern etwa
Berlin und Brandenburg sonst lassen die
Regenfälle nach im Westen ist es auch
mal nur locker bewölkt dann bildet sich
rasch Nebel denn dann sinken die
Temperaturen auf drei oder vier Grad
sonst sind es meist sieben bis vier Grad
und noch kälter ist es hier im Süden
Baden-Württembergs und Bayerns da sinken
die Wetter auf +2 bis -5 Grad die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen an den
Alpen dann auch nur bei 6 Grad ähnlich
wie hier im Oberpfälzer Wald 12 Grad
werden es dagegen in Ostfriesland und
morgen werden die Regenwolken der Nacht
ein bisschen nach Tasten gedrückt so
regnet es noch am längsten hier am
Thüringer Wald oder auch am Erzgebirge
sonst wechselt mal dichtere Wolken und
mal etwas Sonnenschein miteinander ab
hier und da sind doch einige
Regenschauer nicht völlig ausgeschlossen
bei Wind aus West bis Nordwest in den
nächsten Tagen geht es mit Recht
freundlichem Wetter in Süddeutschland
weiter im Norden sind doch einige
Regenschauer unterwegs das bei
Temperaturen von fünf bis zwölf Grad und
jetzt schauen wir noch auf den Trend für
messstätten da sehen sie nämlich dass
die Temperaturen zunächst nachts vor
allen Dingen in den Frost singen
tagsüber liegen dort die Temperaturen um
5 Grad und das wird sich in den nächsten
zehn Tagen nicht ändern bei freundlichem
Wetter guten Abend